are modern women delusional
so um i want to go around and why don't
we start with what is something that
frustrates you guys about dating
emily you can go first how much time
have we got for this one
um
what frustrates me about dating
ghosting
be one of them
okay
it's close to the heart
ghosting
[Laughter]
sounds personal it's definitely personal
yeah does that happen often or
no i think once is enough oh okay you
get ghostly once that's going to be
sticking with you for life it was like i
feel like that doesn't happen to girls
as much
um i beg to differ about that one oh
okay
does it happen i don't know does it
happen it does yeah you should be
ashamed of yourself
no not you lot the man you like should
do better i'm saying now we should we
should do better like if you're gonna um
stop speaking have the courage of your
convictions to just say just say listen
i'm not gonna listen something's not
working out or i'm not feeling something
about what's happening and we're not
gonna speak anymore i'm gonna go another
direction but the ghosting thing i don't
support
it so what about you guys um
just not stating what you want from the
start like
people who lack honesty
i don't see why you're scared to say
what you want maybe i'll side with you
maybe i won't that's for you to find out
do you feel like are you up front with
what you want
pretty much yeah okay yeah and you feel
like they are they like playing you like
they tell you one thing kind of yeah
kind of in like way to coerce me or
something they wanna they wanna coerce
you what does that mean
like just to
lead me on and then okay at first
they'll make it seem like
they agree with me or they wanna do i
don't know just
okay say for example i wanna get into a
relationship they're like yeah cool and
as soon as they get what they actually
want they'll cut oh like as soon as they
sleep with you they'll be like yeah
something like that okay but
yeah that's another real thing i can
speak from a man's perspective because
all of these things you guys are saying
um i hear about
and i i'm i'm very anti all of that kind
of stuff but it's a real thing now what
you're talking about it's very common
but there's a
degeneration now and men now will tell
you anything you want to tell a woman
anything you want to hear if you say i
like walks in the park they like walks
in the park if you like say like lily's
they're gonna say we like lily's
let's go lily picking
do you feel like it's a thing because
girls like bat out of their league so to
speak
are you asking me yeah as from like a
guy's point
i've heard that theory before you know i
don't i don't i think it's that because
i don't believe in out of your league
when you say out of your league what do
you mean by that you don't you don't
believe in people have leagues but no
but i want you to define what you mean
because there's different there's
different ways i could take it okay so
like you rate someone one to ten so
we've got enough looks yeah it looks
see because it starts with blocks
so you're saying
but that wouldn't explain why they would
lie to you to get what you want because
hypothetically speaking if i'm a 10 and
you're a two i'm going to get what i
want easier i i don't even have to
really lie i could just be like give me
what i want you should be happy to be
around me so you wouldn't really need to
lie for that so i don't think it comes
from that if that's a if that's the
thought process i think it just comes
from a thing of people are selfish now
so there's less of an urge for men to
protect women like they would have been
before that men used to like if you go
back generations and generations your
grandparents there was more of a thing
chivalrous look after women take care of
them protect them and so on and so forth
as time has passed now men are just like
i want what i want and that's it i don't
that's not my experience like i think
most guys
like there's a lot of guys willing to do
that it's just the girls don't want them
you know women women rate the majority
of men is unattractive i think it's like
80 90 percent of men women rate
unattractive
i think women i often say women overlook
some good men you are ignoring the bin
man the pulse man some regular guys you
don't want the flag guys but the flag
guy's got a lot of options so you're
just another one like the bin man and
postman
more appreciative hard-working getting
on with their day-to-day trainer you
know and you don't want him no but
that's what i mean when i say like girls
are batting out of their league because
they're going for the guy that every
girl wants
and so
like of course like that's going to
happen when you go for the guy that
everyone wants
because he'll sleep with a bunch of
girls but like who's he going to commit
to yes so maybe it's not that there's no
maybe it's not out of their league it's
just the wrong choice because she could
be a 10 he could be attempting but his
mentality is wrong because he his
mentality is that i've got all of you so
why do i need you so it's not
necessarily out of the league it's just
a mentality thing like i guess
i wouldn't know because i've always been
a good guy
yeah yeah you've never ghosted a girl
nah nah nah i'm not graceful i was never
ghosted i never goes through that right
you know ghost is a struggle word though
you think i'm good and i just jump out
like boo i'm here so i'd be honest and
up front and just be like listen it's
not working out i'm pretty much a
straight talker okay
um what about you guys do you think that
do you think
women have
do you think women's standards nowadays
are realistic
to an extent it depends on who it is
yes yeah there's definitely i think a
lot of women
yeah but some girls agree with them
i think we know what we're getting
ourselves into a long time
that's what i say i feel like
i feel like most of the time when like
that happens like girls kind of have a
sixth sense or like this guy's up to
something
but we do it anyway and then
like
we cry on the internet
[Laughter]
we know our friends know
everyone we know what we're getting as
well we know they're t's and c's where
it's going to go wrong
but we can't help ourselves why do you
think that is
i'll just go for vibes yeah that's
what's great
but the guys with the vibes those are
the smooth talkers like they had to do
something to get that way
which is like a lot of hoes yeah it
works
it's that short fix of attention isn't
it
yeah i think for a lot of us
it's that short fix and we know it's not
going to last very long but we still
we're still good it's great weather it's
a great one
it's like crack you know what's
interesting um
80 if you ask 80 of women what they want
in a man they list twenty percent of men
so the reason that women hate men is
because we're all sleeping with the same
ones
that is because like do you guys have a
height requirement that you would
i actually i actually don't yeah
no height yeah how tall like um
minimum six foot three oh six do you
know what percent of guys are saying
you just
talk about a big percentage of the ball
um
so i i don't actually know what it is
over six three but over um
six foot is
fifteen percent of men
so i'm assuming i would guess six three
is like ten percent probably less and
then so then let's say let's say like
you're not going to date the six three
guys that are ugly right
it depends actually
you'll be an ugly guy
medium rare medium medium so medium ugly
six three medium ugly and higher so
again like let's say you knock out then
at least 50
of those guys because they're not your
type or whatever um then that's only
five percent now let's say you add on
income like he has to make a certain
amount of money okay he ever
has to make the same as more than me how
much um you don't have to say exactly
but how much do you want him to make
like if you got what you wanted
don't disclose that information
that's not like one gold digger so he's
just like
do you want a guy like takes care of you
though
um i wouldn't necessarily say take care
of me but if he would like to i don't
mind but i can actually take care of
myself okay so income isn't as big but
oh that's that's serious
how tall are you i'm five foot eight
five eight okay
that's all right
like i like to wear heels a lot so
that's fair he has to be taller than me
in my heels at least because
too many guys are short
so sad
so um question
since women like have
are able to say like i want a guy that's
taller than me do you think men should
be able to say like i don't want to date
fat girls
that's why
they should be able to say that with
chess yeah if that's how they feel
why not i mean
you like what you're liking it um you
just said you don't like no if he's up
at the six foot like what because like
what if the guy was like
i'm just saying you like what you like
yeah
it was funny because we can like as
girls we could talk about this openly
but if a guy says like oh there's too
many fat girls around no but you know
what it's like um
the way guys go about it because
sometimes the fat girls aren't even
checking for them
what sorry some sometimes the fat girls
aren't even checking for them but they
just feel the need to slander them
anyways
like me i'm not going around saying i
don't like guys under six foot three
like you're ugly i wouldn't go up to
some short guy in the street and tell
him
no but girls but girls say things like
men are trash men ain't [ __ ] many like
like girls talk [ __ ] on men all the time
but the second a guy does it back like
all hell is broken it's like
i wouldn't
i'd be like it's just off of like a
small experience that they had i don't
think they send it for all men but the
men that it applies to you
are the ones that are getting triggered
well it's the same thing with girls
the girls that the girls that it applies
to gets triggered yeah i don't get
triggered it's not me absolutely i think
maybe because yeah i think everyone's
entitled to say what their personal
preferences are yeah so if a man decides
that he doesn't want you know a more
fat is a strong word
fluffy
you know i think it's down to the
individual that's how i'd be looking at
if i've got a personal preference that i
don't want that's for me to decide and
if a woman feels the same way okay
that's fine yeah that's for them to
decide that's how i see it but you're
not gonna tell me you're not gonna try
and attack me because i say i don't want
her to to be with someone that's you
know
a certain whatever okay but we do get
attacked often and i'm glad that you
brought that to the forefront yeah we do
men do well even if i hear guys say like
i won't date a single mom like girls
freak out yeah like why not for that i
i'm not going to comment on that no
please do
something like i don't really
dive into that type of topic so it's
just like
i don't know
i'm here for it what are you saying well
i just think like whenever men say they
want to have standards they're shamed
for it so if they say like i don't want
a girl that's fat i don't want to go
with kids i don't want to grow this like
like men will be immediately shamed but
but women can say i want a guy that
makes six figures he needs to be six
foot tall he needs to have this this and
this
he but
and no one will say anything i agree i
agree i agree i think women often have a
lot of like their list their tick boxes
but actually they're not bringing much
to the table themselves yeah see i don't
know see for me i think that it's i hear
what you're saying and women do do all
of these things and
a lot of the times i say i feel like
it's everything's in the men's favor
right now if you're
if you're on point
yeah that's a small percentage of men
shout out to us
but
for i understand what you're saying but
for the rest yeah it's going to be a
tough time but if you're on point it's
definitely everything's in your favor
right now as far as the criteria that
women are putting out for themselves
because they're you're you're you're
making the pool smaller and smaller
you understand what i'm saying so with
the i don't want this he's got to have
that he's got to have this he's got to
do that yeah the pool's getting smaller
and smaller so the ones that
now have all of the
all of the things you've asked for
they've got they've got a broad spectrum
to choose from there that's why you
might end up getting hurt
well it's not conducive for families
and that's the problem is like 50 of
women over 30 are projected to be single
and childless
and like by 35 you you hit geriatric
pregnancy 90 of your eggs are gone by
30.
geriatric essentially
shout out r.i.p kevin samuels for the
thing he was saying the other day about
the over 35s and what do you say again
leftover women yep
i didn't catch it fully but i got the
general gist
leftover thing
do you think that's is that offensive to
you guys
i think that's kind of offensive that's
kind of harsh because that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's
that's
that's
that's
that's that's correct
unless it applies for men to you i feel
it's quite realistic if one is in that
position myself being okay i'm not past
35 and 31
but
perhaps i could see why men might feel
that way about me it's not right i don't
agree with it
but i can understand it
i think it's it's somewhat true and it's
not it's not like a fun reality like one
day i'm gonna be 35.
like hopefully hopefully i'll be married
but i don't know that yeah but
like i think it's honest at least like
guys are attracted to fertility and
youth
yeah but you can get the oh but
it depends what you want yeah because
you can you still get a relationship
i don't think you can get a relationship
at 45. so it depends what your outlook
looking for you're talking about
children and and all of the above
obviously your time shortening but as
far as meeting someone and having a
happy relationship i don't think there's
an age limit on that because you could
meet someone at
whatever age yeah it was true but like
according to dating apps you're um
like 50 of your options are gone by the
time you're 30. so if you take the same
girl at 23 or at 20 and 30 if you take
like the number of matches she gets on
dating apps it goes down by 50 see this
is the thing
you're americans you love your
statistics for everything we're dealing
with we have to take life into
consideration and some kismet stuff
going on as well because sometimes
things just happen we're not it can't
all even those stats are obviously
there's obviously credence to those
stacks at the same time
there's still you know that variable of
life you could walk out right now bump
into someone and everything changes so
i'm not going to write off the ladies
demo over 35 just yet because
you know shout out my over 35 full easel
with that you know i still could be a
nice man don't let you know kevin break
you down it's still go it will still
happen at any time yeah but but is it
likely to the likelihood might it's
significantly down but it's not it's not
it's far from impossible that's true
it's far from impossible and like you
can bear in mind when you're over 35 all
the 20 year old where's the running are
chasing after you as what that is true
yeah that is absolutely true
no fiction so you so you have the
potential to turn the tables as well
and you know some of them will just be
looking for fun but some of them you
could potentially if that was the
direction you chose to go you could
potentially mold them a certain kind of
way as well just like men do when when
we have our second um our second go
around and decide all right it's not
worked out i'm gonna get my girl she's
23 and we're gonna have a relationship
now you understand so i'm just saying
that i don't i don't want to they're
over 45 to be feeling all down and
depressed right now so i'm trying to
help people out
it's not about making them feel down and
depressed it's about being it's not it's
about being honest right but i'm being
honest yeah i'm a listen i'm the oldest
person in the room yeah so i've i've
experienced life i've seen things i know
people of all age ranges and i'm just
saying that it's not a right off for you
i know a lot of women of this age are
not a lot of women that might be single
and a lot of women that find happiness
at these ages so even though
statistically the odds are against you
it's not impossible that's all i'm
saying that's true that's true i mean if
you if you're in shape you're above like
i don't know what it is here but you're
if you're in shape you're above like
what seventy-five percent of women
that's just there you go first yeah
but that's the exception not the rule
most people don't most people don't age
like better what would this that we
established here from what you've said
so yeah
if you're a fat single mum over 35 you
better get to the gym right now get
yourself ready get your [ __ ]
get your [ __ ] back get yourself in the
gym and help out cause if you have got a
banging body and listen there's some
women
in their 30s and 40s you see them in the
gym they're going hard on that step
machine they're in an incredible shape
they're they're getting in shape like
they're they're
their future husband just like yeah
they're like yeah they're going hard are
they going to go even harder after this
they're going hard no don't blame them
yeah letting them carry on carry on
sorry i'll just say i'm just saying but
like i think it makes sense like single
like people over 35 are the left over
the women because the ones no one else
picked